hello everyone and welcome to the world
rapid and blitz championship that starts
today and it's gonna be played out
throughout the next five days we're
gonna have three days of rapid that's 15
rounds of rapid and then two days of
blitz to decide the New World rapid and
the new blitz champion in round one it's
Magnus Carlsen versus automatic galiyev
a well not a grandmaster he's a player
from Kazakhstan and he he doesn't have a
title but he he is rated over twenty
five hundred twenty-five hundred and
fifty so I definitely plays with the
strength of a grandmaster I don't know
why he's untitled but I'm sure there's a
very good reason for it and we we do
have a venue a nice photo of the venue
there you have it this is the moscow
solution iki stadium this is where the
world rapid and blitz championship is
being played so there you have it
it's really beautiful even though the
organizers are Saudi Arabia the venue is
well the championship takes place in
Moscow for certain reasons so that being
said let's check out the game round one
Magnus with the white pieces opens with
E 4 and we have d5 very interesting
since the previous game we've shown is
cross and actually played the the
Scandinavian against the early days of
Ferrara and it is the the same variation
he captures Queen captures Knight c3 and
now this Queen to d6 line seems to be
becoming very popular
Magnus goes d4 we have c6 and now Knight
to f3 so just going for some nice
development Knight f3 and now Knight to
e5 a very nice output for the night 9b
d7 hoping to trade off some pieces and
not nice to see for getting the Queen to
a less active square we have Queen back
to c7 and now weiter will continue his
attack with Queen f3 Bishop to f4 where
he can further harass the Queen
but first Magnus includes a 4 but okay
with a 5 black does the same and now
there is one game where g3 was played
Queen to f3 now is a new move the winter
3 wouldn't be a new move without the
inclusion of a 4 but would inclusion it
is but it's pretty much the same idea we
have night the b6 again offering a trade
of knights and now Bishop to f4
forcing the Queen
further back Queen back to d8 and now we
have Bishop to e5 you do have to defend
the d4 pawn somehow if you just Castle
then the ship g4 will win some material
for black so instead there should be
five magnets just defends the pawn this
way and now Bishop g4 doesn't really do
anything is simply Queen g3 and already
you have threats of Bishop characters
and and the Queen just winning a piece
so night the night B to d5 centralizing
in the other night and now Magnus traits
and it's it's a good trade for white
because the black is unable to capture
with the Queen due to Knight b6 and now
after you trade Queens
you will lose material here you cannot
save both the rook and the bishop
because the BH square is covered by the
dark square bishop so Knight captures on
d5 and then now we have c3 strengthening
the center and Knight back to f6 now now
black has to decide how to develop
further develop his pieces he's gonna
play Bishop to e6 but then he wants the
first trade of his light square bishop
not doing anything for the moment and
then he's gonna play e6 to get the
bishop into the game and hopefully
finish development there should be three
Magnus is ready to castle and Bishop to
e6 now as planned
Magnus just castles and now Bishop
captures on c4 Bishop captures and now
II 6 now now one of the bishops has been
traded but Magnus remains with the
bishop pair and plays Queen to g3 makes
it harder for black to develop now if
there should be 70 just a grab on on g7
so g6 preparing to fianchetto the bishop
but now Magnus goes
f4 with the idea of pushing f5 he wants
to bust open the position as black
skinny stone in the center of the board
d5 was also playable since it's
impossible for black to just capture the
pawn the night can't capture because
well you lose the rook if you capture
with the pondan just bishop check you
don't have a good move here if you move
the King Bishop here just the wins the
Queen or or it doesn't you just move the
Queen and then you get checkmate it and
it's interesting that if you capture
with this point
it also doesn't work just rook F e1 and
you don't have an escape against all of
this nasty discoveries if better be
just pick up the knight and the bishop
is pinned you'll be unable to capture if
you try and escape Queen h3 check you
just bounced the King right back to the
e-file and then just you know or all the
nasty discoveries win the game so d5 was
actually perfectly winning here but okay
with f4 Bishop to g7 and mount f5 Magnus
calculates that this will be just as
efficient
we have EK you cannot capture with this
point since the bishop falls if you do
nothing then just captures on e6 is very
strong the bishop or already attacks
this square so it captures an f5 was
played but now Magnus just opens up the
e-file for the rook with tempo so Bishop
c7 attacks the Queen Queen to c8 and now
Queen to b6 taking away the f8 Square
from the black King and now the rook is
coming in to inter play so nice to e4
blocking of the e-file but just look 81
and here Queen to d7 luta galiyev hopes
to trade off Queens and then continue
the game but Magnus has something else
in store so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the winning idea for
Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on finding
either of the two ideas if you found
Bishop captures on f7 that works but
it's just a different move order Magnus
played rook captures on e4 which is
basically the same line you are now in
check you have to react to this so the
rook has to be captured we have F
captures and now Bishop captures on f7
just taking away all the squares from
the black King now the the black queen
is forced to capture which means white
wins the Queen also you have to now
capture the rogue because there's the
main threat just Queen e7 King captures
on f7 was played and here Magnus just
played Queen to d7 check and it was in
this position on move 27 626 that
automatically if resigned the game and a
nice victory for Magnus Carlsen in round
1 if you remember last year
Magnus lost his game in round 1 which
really you know affected the rest of the
tournament so here he really took it
seriously and he played well a fairly
perfect game that d5 could have been
an improvement but it's a rapid game no
point wasting your time to look for you
know some fancy moves so now here he
resigned because if the King moves just
checking f8 and Bishop d6 is made and if
you want to go down the board it's not
really going to be any better just
Bishop e5 check-in g5 Queen d7 checking
moves and now you can just threaten mate
and there's no way to defend if h6 you
just page 3 then g4 will be made and if
g5 you just you know rush the King down
the board king each for you give up a
bishop captures and now Queen to f2 is
made so pretty much everything black
does not pretty much everything black
does his mate so after Queen b7 he
resigns and well a very interesting
start to the tournament Magnus wins his
first game so there we have it we're
gonna try and cover as many games as
possible although so many games are
being played that we're probably gonna
focus on the top boards and maybe
tomorrow you know hopefully some of you
will check out some other games as well
and use hash tag suggestion to to tell
me of all the other nice games that were
played so I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Doug McNab Edward
Baker Maxime piece an entry 1998 and the
Torrens fight for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual
you are welcome to check - in my
previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see you soon
like I said for the next five days we
are covering the world rapid and blitz
championship in Moscow so thank y'all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your days more games soon to
come